solid liquid gas the whole universe is
made of these three phases of matter
right wrong matter comes in a lot more
varieties than you might think the three
phases of water that we're most familiar
with water vapor in clouds steam or
liquid water
in addition to liquid they're solid or
ice notice how the phase or order
increases as the temperature decreases
and it gets more chaotic and random as
the temperature increases
put ice on a table it'll still keep its
shape for a little while till it cools
out forming liquid water which will then
flow over the entire surface eventually
if you heat it up steam will flow
outwards and it will move in all
directions temperature is tied to
thermal energy which is a measure of how
chaotic a physical system is well as it
turns out that doesn't just apply to
small objects like ice and water
molecules the whole universe can be
considered to have phases as well the
more energy in a given part of the
universe the more chaotic that part
becomes from active volcanoes on
exoplanets or moons to nebulae to the
swirling cores of galaxies harboring
supermassive black holes what's even
more chaotic than gas that's what
lightning bolts in the visible part of
fire and even the emission from enormous
black holes are comprised of it it's
called plasma with its incredibly High
thermal energy plasmas are some of the
most well-known
destructive forces of nature often
called the fourth phase of matter
rewinding a little bit notice that the
phases of water are distinct there's no
mistaking whether you're looking at ice
water or gas that's because the bonds
between water molecules have different
well-calculated Energies
when you excite the system beyond what
those bonds can handle they break apart
and dissociate new weaker bonds can take
their place but eventually you can
dissociate those as well now phases
aren't always this obvious how about
slime
it can hold its shape but slowly forms
into a shapeless puddle there's also
asphalt you'd think that our roads made
of the substance would be pretty much
Rock Solid but this famous pitch drop
experiment shows us that asphalt and
similar materials are actually
non-Newtonian fluids too they're flowing
glass even flows ancient glass and
Cathedrals and older structures shows a
thickening towards the bottom because
the glass is slowly flowing even though
it looks very solid over Millennia and
so it's actually thicker at the bottom
due to gravitational flowing pulling on
the glass molecules like people some
things change Under Pressure you can
actually make your own non-Newtonian
fluid it's called Oobleck mix two part
parts of cornstarch to one part of water
what you get is Oobleck a weird
non-Newtonian material that's a solid
when you hit it hard or apply sudden
pressure but a liquid when you touch it
softly or apply light pressure in
oobleck's case the water molecules break
up the cornstarch normally making
everything flow like liquid if you apply
pressure though the water gets forced
out and the cornstarch binds to itself
kind of like a solid two different
phases coexisting and only differing due
to applied external forces not something
intrinsic now let's shrink things down
and get small smaller than atoms
we're looking at electrons we've
discussed the applications of
superconductors we use them in the
Simon's Observatory as our detector
mechanism they're a Mainstay of what's
called condensed matter physics and have
been on the scene since 1911 when good
old camerlin honest discovered the first
superconductor when he liquefied helium
and demonstrated the property of zero
electrical resistance as a function of
temperature in ordinary materials in
this case lead incredibly there's
another phase change that we've talked
about in previous videos along with
Nobel Prize winner Bill Phillips in this
video that I'll link to above in the
study of what are called Bose-Einstein
condensates what are these exotic phases
of matter well suppose you're lost in a
crowd at the mall everyone's going this
way and that their own way their own
identity and their own fashion sense you
can glance at a person and tell exactly
how they're different from the person
standing next to them now instead
imagine you're in a crowd at a concert
for a man you love everyone's stressed
and moving and acting more or less the
same way right as you get more Harmony
more synchronization across the crowd
the individuals within that crowd become
harder and harder to distinguish from
one another if you take it to the
extreme you get a condensate
which is not applicable to ordinary
human beings but it's an extremely
orderly state of matter where the
individual particles become impossible
to distinguish superconductors make use
of this property but hold that thought
for now normally electrons are what are
considered fermions
these are subatomic particles that can
only exist if they each have their own
unique Quantum state or identity they
follow the so-called Paulie exclusion
principle that prevents them from
occupying the same energy states at the
same time however if you cool them down
enough they can form what's called a
Cooper pair named after Leon Cooper my
professor of quantum mechanics at Brown
University where I got my PhD
connections I made here endure to this
day Leon discovered this phenomena
allegedly riding a subway car back in
the 1950s and solved a problem known for
50 years that even the Great Richard
Feynman couldn't solve why was he
jealous when he found out what Cooper
bardeen and schreefer came up with it
was inconceivable and does something to
them this means that the individual
particles which are themselves fermions
can bond together becoming a boson which
then lose in the Cooper pair
configuration lose their individuality
and can be compressed and occupy the
same state it could even have an
infinite number of them in the same
state some instead of a stream of
individual fermionic electrons flowing
through a piece of metal you have an
indeterminate sea of electrons that can
seamlessly adapt to any change in the
electric potential flowing without
resistance that's what a superconductor
is the goal of many of my colleagues is
to form a so-called high temperature or
even a room temperature superconductor
which could be used for transportation
having power generation and power
transportation across the world without
loss and this would be a revolution for
Humanity and many people think it's just
around the corner the ship from
Individual fermionic electrons to Cooper
pairs in the formation of a
Bose-Einstein condensate inside of a
crystal lattice and metal lattice it
allows a uniform motion of the
superconducting electrons it's a type of
phase change fermionic deposonic it's
pretty cool right literally
now the BCS or bardeen Cooper schreifer
superconductivity doesn't apply to all
types of superconductors there are
so-called unconventional superconductors
they don't follow BCS so there's more of
the story than we have time for today
let's leave it at the understanding of
the formation of a condensate of
electrons marking a phase change from
non-superconductor to superconductor and
the phase is characterized by an order
parameter and that order parameter is
controlled by the temperature of the
system
superconductors and the phase change
involved is happening on the very very
small Scale of the Universe for your
large scale things may be much the same
many cosmologists believe that the
Universe has gone through a series of
phase changes we have evidence that the
Universe has dissociated the four laws
of physics into at least three different
laws the laws of electricity and
magnetism that are United at a high
enough temperature are low enough
temperature depending on your
perspective with the weak nuclear force
forming the electro weak Theory now that
is a type of phase change from these
forces being separate and distinct to
them having a combined unified existence
where they can be described as a single
Force the electro weak force it may be
true that the strong nuclear force can
be unified with the Elixir weak theory
that would create a so-called Grand
unified theory and if we can modify and
incorporate gravity we'd get the
so-called Theory of Everything the t-o-e
and many people are trying to study the
theory of everything and perhaps
overlooking the gut the grand unified
theory so I don't want to put the toe
ahead of the gut very good doctor very
good part of what we have in the early
Universe could also represent a phase
transition during so-called inflation
which we've talked about many times and
we'll continue to talk about the
universe definitely did evolve from
extremely high temperatures when it was
dominated by radiation to then being
dominated by ordinary matter that's not
relativistic and eventually currently
dominated by what is called Dark Energy
those are different types of phases of
the universe's Evolution and in each
phase the universe would have a
different expansion history and
properties so-called Hubble parameter
will change based on the composition
that dominates the universe radiation
matter or dark energy let's examine
another type of phase change using
magnets any magnet you've seen has a
north and south side or a positive and
negative side if you will these opposite
sides will attract and you can attract a
compass needle to either the North or
South Pole all depending on its North or
South Pole these Opposites Attract north
to south and vice versa like Paul's
North and North will repel each other
just like South Poles along with other
South Poles we don't believe there is a
magnetic monopole as I discussed in this
video in that if you break a magnet
apart you won't get an isolated North
and South Pole you'll get two North
Poles and two South Poles one on each of
the individual halves now magnets can
exhibit phase transitions as well and
this was discovered by none other than
Marie Curie the great Madame Curie
observed that if a magnet is heated
above a certain temperature it loses its
magnetism that temperature is called the
Curie point it goes from being a
magnetic magnetized phase to completely
unmagnetized that is a phase change
there we go no applause and then
abstract sense we have more than just
solid liquid and gas to characterize the
properties of materials and the forces
of nature itself and that brings us back
to the very beginning perhaps inflation
nope not the rising cost of bread and
gas but cosmological inflation the idea
that at some point in the extremely
early Universe a Quantum field pervaded
the universe called the inflaton
fluctuations in the inflaton cause
different variations in the universe's
space-time curvature providing places
for ordinary matter and dark matter to
accumulate later leading to the
formation of the first Stars galaxies
clusters and eventually planets look
familiar people podcasters as we talked
about in our video on magnetic monopoles
there could have been a surplus of
magnetic monopoles produced in the early
universe that were then inflated or
spread out such that there might be only
one in our entire observable universe
the one that glass Cabrera a claimed to
detect back in the 1980s on the
so-called Valentine's Day event
but we don't have direct evidence for
this theoretical phase change between
the pre-inflationary plasma and the
later post-inflationary primordial soup
that formed the protons and neutrons
that later formed the lightest elements
on the periodic table the inflation
phase is very similar to the
superconductor phase that we already
discussed the transition from
disorganized to organized
again as a function of temperature as an
order parameter that could lead to a
very different early universe that could
have just the right properties to create
the very very Dynamic spectrum of
different variables that we observe in
our universe different phases of matter
and spectrum of forces and their
strengths it can be very very similar to
superconductivity in fact some people
have speculated Dark Matter could be the
manifestation of a superconducting
phenomenon so everything from electrons
to ordinary matter to the universe
itself has phases that describe its
Behavior through changing properties
and if you want to know more about the
experimental quest to understand these
phases in extreme conditions and
fascinating experiments just click here
[Music]